là on a un essieu à périgueux lorsqu une
pellicule arrive au laboratoire du cncc
par cette machine qu'elle passe en
premier dans cette essuyage les plus
petits défauts du film comme les poêles
ou les poussières sont enlevées de vue
émergé à la sortie la pellicule et
propre est prêt à passer à la prochaine
étape la tireuse les certains films sont
trop abîmés pour aller directement en
machine et doivent passer par une
restauration manuel beaucoup plus poussé
avec des produits que vous voyez en
dessous assouplir le film parce que on
continue décompose en règle générale et
se solidifient il devient très dur et
cassant ce qui nous empêche totalement
de les passer en machine en fait
très bon exemple pour te heureusement
telle est unanime et construit là sur ce
film les perforations sont abîmés ou
arracher une casse qui est souvent due à
un passage trop récurrent en machine de
projection alain va devoir réaliser une
colle ura l'acétone pour rajouter les
perforations manquantes
la plupart des les entraînements machine
se font avec des petites griffes des
petits picots qui vont attraper des
perforations et entraîné le film s'il
n'y a plus de faire formation
entraînement n'est pas possible lorsque
les perforations sont restaurés le film
est en état pour passer à la tireuse
c'est ici que les films seront
sauvegardés en dupliquant le film sur un
nouveau support
la majeure partie des pellicules qui
passe sur cette machine sont les films
les plus anciens sur support en nitrates
ici transposée sur support de sécurité
car la sauvegarde reste l'objectif
premier
le but en argentique c'est vraiment pas
mal de préserver le maximum mais négatif
d'origine on pas que pour pas qu'ils
s'abîment plus à force de manipulations
le but de base et des neuf films ici
c'est vraiment d'obtenir un nouvel
élément par exemple si un film on n'a
qu'un seul négatif du négatif c'est pas
en soi
un élément de travail c'est vraiment le
pic et on va faire un positif pour
ensuite faire un contrat type k
négatif qu'il a est voué à être
travaillés les avant de pouvoir
travailler dessus le négatif doit passer
par l'étape du développement sur cet
appareil
la pellicule va rentrer d'un côté et
passé par plusieurs bains et produits
son contenu dans la pellicule pour les
à la sortie de la machine l'image
apparaît enfin sur le film un film qui
va devenir le principal support de
travail pour le cnc permettant à
l'original d'être préserver et conserver
encore plus longtemps